En el extremo sur de la península ibérica,
enclavado en plena provincia española de
Cádiz y rodeado de una de las zonas económica
y socialmente más deprimidas de toda Europa,
se encuentra Gibraltar.
Para los que nos estáis viendo desde España
este territorio británico de ultramar no
necesita presentación. Cada dos por tres,
por un motivo u otro, copa grandes espacios
en los medios de comunicación. En algunos
casos por noticias tan “marcianas” como
esta:
(Ortega Smith, petición de 10 años de cárcel
en Gibraltar por robar un bloque de hormigón.
La Voz del Sur)
(Smith (Vox) dice a los "piratas" de Gibraltar
que no le amedrentan sus órdenes de detención:
"El Peñón vive del delito". Europa Press)
En cambio, para los que nos veis desde cualquier
otro lugar del mundo, puede incluso que no
conozcáis de nada esta pequeña ciudad [si
es que la podemos llamar así] de apenas 34.000
habitantes,
Una diminuta ciudad que España considera
como la última posesión o colonia del Reino
Unido en el continente europeo.
(Gibraltar es un territorio británico de
ultramar cuya soberanía fue entregada por
los españoles a los británicos mediante
el conocido Tratado de Utrecht en 1713 como
parte del acuerdo de paz tras la guerra de
sucesión española que llevó a los borbones
al poder.
Pese a ellos las disputas y las reclamaciones
territoriales sobre la ciudad, las aguas que
la circunda o parte del territorio que ocupa
se han mantenido hasta el día de hoy.)
Ahora bien, ¿por qué demonios en VisualPolitik
hablamos de un recondito, diminuto y aparentemente
intrascendente lugar? ¿A quién le importa
realmente Gibraltar?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas, y si os digo
que el Peñón se ha convertido en uno de
los territorios más prósperos y ricos del
mundo.
Atentos.
España considera a Gibraltar como la última
colonia británica
en territorio europeo. Sin embargo, siendo
justos, esta es una definición que tiene
más agujeros que un queso gruyer.
Por ejemplo, el ejecutivo gibraltareño está
actualmente liderado por este hombre, el Ministro
Principal Fabian Picardo.
Un hombre que junto con su equipo de gobierno
disfrutan de grado de independencia y autogobierno
prácticamente total en lo que respecta al
territorio, lo que incluye, incluso, poder
desarrollar regulaciones, impuestos y normas
completamente diferentes a las del resto del
Reino Unido.
Además, y a pesar de contar con solo 34.000
habitantes, Gibraltar tiene también su propia
Constitución, su última reforma se llevó
a cabo en 2006 y lo cierto es que reforma
tras reforma el gobernador británico ha ido
perdiendo peso en favor de las autoridades
locales. Hasta el punto de que en la práctica
bien podríamos hablar de un territorio que
de facto en en gran medida independiente.
Por si fuera poco en 1967 el 99.64% de los
gibraltareños votaron en un referéndum a
favor de seguir bajo la soberanía británica.
Y en 2002 ni más ni menos que el 98.97% de
los gibraltareños rechazó en otro referéndum
la soberanía compartida con España.
Así que por mucho que tantos y tantos políticos
en España se empeñen en hablar de colonia,
la realidad parece muy distinta.
Con todo, y a pesar de su escasa población,
el tema Gibraltar volvió a copar todas las
portadas y el debate político en la España
del 2016.
¿Por qué? Pues atentos.
("[Tras el Brexit] la bandera española está
ahora mucho más cerca de Gibraltar" José
Manuel García-Margallo y Marfil, Ministro
de Exteriores de España entre 2011 y 2016)
Exacto, el Brexit lo cambió todo. El resultado
del referéndum en Gibraltar fue contundente:
ni más ni menos que el 95,9% de los gibraltareños,
también conocidos como los llanitos, se opusieron
al mismo. Lo que no resulta para nada extraño.
El miedo a quedarse aislados y a sufrir perjuicios
de todo tipo por las trabas fronterizas empujó
a los gibraltareños a sumarse con fuerza
a la campaña contra el Brexit.
Y es que, por ejemplo, la economía de Gibraltar
depende en gran medida de los más de 9.000
trabajadores españoles que cada día cruzan
la frontera para trabajar en este territorio
británico. Así que ya os podéis imaginar
el grado de integración que existe.
Pese a ello, la salida del Reino Unido del
club comunitario es ya una realidad.
Y eso ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos hagamos
unas cuantas preguntas.
¿Qué futuro le aguarda a Gibraltar? ¿De
qué demonios vive exactamente el Peñón?
Y ojo, porque creo que las respuestas os van
a sorprender. Queridos amigos, amigas, como
os decía antes Gibraltar se ha convertido
en uno de los lugares más prósperos de todo
el mundo.
Atentos.
(¿LA”ROCA” MÁS PRÓSPERA?)
Queridos amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik,
Gibraltar se ha convertido en un territorio
tremendamente próspero. Y qué queréis que
os diga, eso, eso es algo que se nota.
Entrar en Gibraltar implica experimentar una
diferencia abismal respecto a la situación
socioeconómica del territorio español que
lo rodea. Es prácticamente como pasar de
la noche a la mañana.
Mientras que entrar en Gibraltar supone darse
de bruces con torres y urbanizaciones de lujo
en construcción, coches de alta gama, negocios
en auge y una tasa de desempleo de menos del
1%, la situación al otro lado de la frontera
es completamente distinta.
Ahí está, por ejemplo, el caso de la Línea
de la Concepción. Fijaos.
(La Línea de la Concepción, la ciudad española
que hace frontera con Gibraltar, padece una
situación económica y social muy complicada.
Es de hecho, protagonista habitual de los
realitys televisivos enfocados a cuestiones
de crímenes, marginalidad y narcóticos.
Con alrededor de un 70% de desempleo juvenil
en algunos barrios deprimidos, la ciudad y
toda su comarca circundante, el Campo de Gibraltar,
son pasto del narcotráfico y la inseguridad.
Se calcula que más de 3.000 personas participan
del tráfico de estupefacientes que llegan
desde África. Junto a ello, el contrabando
de alcohol, tabaco y las ayudas públicas
son algunas de las principales actividades
del entorno.)
Evidentemente las diferencias se notan por
los cuatro costados. ¿Queréis algunos ejemplos?
Pues fijaos: mientras que en la Línea el
salario medio apenas supera los 17.000 euros
anuales, apenas a unos pocos cientos de metros
de distancia, en Gibraltar este salario promedio
se multiplica por más de 2 hasta superar
los 36.000 euros.
Y, ojo,porque si utilizamos otras estadísticas
como la inversión o la productividad, las
diferencias son aún mayores. De hecho, basta
con que echemos un vistazo a la producción
económica de este territorio para entender
de qué estamos hablando exactamente
Pues bien, para que os hagáis una idea, a
pesar de sus 34.000 habitantes y de su ridícula
dimensión, se espera que el PIB supere pronto
los 3.500 millones de dólares, una cifra
que ya había sido batida antes de la pandemia.
Hablamos de un PIB per cápita de unos 100
mil dólares.
Es decir, que mientras Gibraltar se está
convirtiendo en uno de los territorios más
prósperos de Europa e incluso de todo el
mundo - con una tasa de crecimiento real medio
de casi el 7% anual durante los 10 años previos
al coronavirus - la zona española que lo
rodea es por contra una de las áreas más
deprimidas de la Unión Europea.
Ahora bien, la pregunta que podemos hacernos…
Es, ¿De dónde demonios sacan el dinero los
llanitos, los gibraltareños? ¿Cómo puede
un lugar tan diminuto ser tan próspero?
Pues evidentemente con apenas 6,8km2 de superficie,
la mayor parte de ellos, además ocupados
por la gran roca, por el enorme peñón, las
opciones son limitadas:
0% sector primario y prácticamente 0% industria.
Este territorio se dedica casi por completo
a los servicios. Podemos encontrar 4 actividades
destacadas:
El puerto, las finanzas, el turismo y tal
vez por encima de todo el juego en línea.
(Gibraltar es uno de los principales puertos
del mar Mediterráneo para el repostaje de
combustible, el conocido como bunkering y
que constituye entre el 85 y el 90% de la
actividad total del puerto.
Su liderazgo en esta materia se explica en
buena medida gracias a que el repostaje de
barcos mercantes en Gibraltar está libre
de impuestos.
La segunda gran actividad de Gibraltar son
las finanzas y los seguros, una industria
que el gobierno local lleva años promoviendo.
Tanto es así que a pesar de ser un sitio
tan pequeño, cuenta con alrededor de 20 bancos
internacionales con sede o sucursal, donde
se dedican casi en exclusiva a la gestión
de activos financieros offshore.
Ojo, Gibraltar no es un paraíso fiscal, pero
sí ha puesto sobre la mesa una regulación
ágil e impuestos moderados. Por ejemplo,
no grava las ganancias de capital y fue una
de las primeras jurisdicciones de todo el
planeta en crear un marco regulatorio adaptado
a las Fintech.
Otro ejemplo, su relativamente reducido impuesto
sobre los beneficios empresariales, actualmente
del 12,5%, ha contribuido a que muchas empresas
establezcan su sede en este lugar, hasta el
punto de que hay unas 20.000 empresas en este
pequeño territorio de 34.000 habitantes)
Luego, el turismo es otro de los grandes atractivos
de este lugar. Cada año entre 11 y 12 millones
de turistas y visitantes llegan al peñón,
lo que supone una de las tasas de turistas
en relación a los residentes más altas de
todo el mundo.
Y no, no es algo casual.
Además de su peculiaridades y hasta ahora
ausencia de impuestos indirectos, el desarrollo
turístico y la atracción de grandes fortunas
es algo que las autoridades y los empresarios
locales se han tomado muy, pero que muy en
serio.
Ahí está por ejemplo el desarrollo de puertos
deportivos como el Ocean Village, que veis
en pantalla.
O, también, actualmente la inversión de
300 millones de dólares para desarrollar
Victoria Keys, un complejo de 130.000m2 ganados
al mar que contendrá entre otros 1.500 apartamentos
de lujo, espacios comerciales y un hotel.
Pero esperad un momento, porque si hay una
industria en la que Gibraltar destaca a nivel
mundial esa no es otra que el juego en línea,
los casinos online.
Y es que, veréis, desde que en 2005 el gobierno
del peñón sacará adelante una nueva ley
del juego en 2005, esta industria se ha disparado
hasta tal punto que algunas de las principales
empresas de juego online de todo el mundo
están instaladas justo aquí, en el Peñon..
Estoy hablando de empresas como William Hill,
888, o Betfred entre otras muchas.
Gibraltar es un enorme hub mundial del juego
online. Ahora bien, ¿por qué? ¿Por qué
estas empresas han escogido este
Pues… entre otras cosas porque este lugar
tiene una de las regulaciones más avanzadas
del mundo, una comisión regulatoria que trata
de avanzar con los tiempos - se la juegan
todo a ser competitivos - y un bajo impuesto
sobre el juego.
("Gibraltar tiene un enfoque favorable para
los negocios que hace que sea fácil para
las buenas empresas establecerse y operar.
Hay muchos asesores locales listos para apoyar
la creación, y los representantes gubernamentales
pertinentes y sus equipos son accesibles y
prácticos en su apoyo". Julian Jarvis es
el CEO de Pragmatic Play.)
En total, la industria financiera y el juego
online suponen alrededor del 40% de todo el
PIB local.
Queridos amigos, amigas, tal y como hemos
visto en otras ocasiones, una de las grandes
ventajas que tienen estas micro jurisdicciones
es que tanto las autoridades como la propia
población tienen muchos incentivos a explotar
sus ventajas competitivas.
Hasta el punto que habitualmente se comportan
casi como empresas con una misión: adaptarse
a los tiempos lo más rápidamente posible
y maximizar la creación de actividad económica.
Y ese es precisamente el caso del peñón,
de Gibraltar, cuyo gobierno tendrá muchas
cosas criticables, pero no solo adopta constantemente
regulaciones avanzadas y competitivas para
la industria de servicios profesionales, sino
que trabaja a destajo para atraer empresas
e inversiones, sacar adelante proyectos de
alto valor y mejorar el ecosistema local.
Por ejemplo, a pesar de tener solo 34.000
habitantes en 2015 comenzó a operar su propio
mercado de valor: La bolsa de Gibraltar.
Los resultados saltan a la vista.
Sin embargo, un momento, porque ahora el Brexit
ha supuesto todo un punto de inflexión. Y
la pregunta que podemos hacernos es, ¿hasta
qué punto Gibraltar puede salir perjudicado
o beneficiado de toda esta revolución política?
Atentos.
(EL PEÑON TRAS EL BREXIT)
A pesar de lo que muchos creen, lo cierto
es que por ahora el Brexit en Gibraltar en
la práctica, y salvo por la sustitución
de la bandera europea por la de la Commonwealth,
no se ha notado demasiado.
Esto ha sido así porque las condiciones de
salida del Reino Unido de la Unión Europea
no se aplicaban a Gibraltar, cuya situación
acordó negociarse por separado.
Y, precisamente, para evitar un Brexit duro
que hubiera supuesto muchas trabas tanto para
el peñón como para los trabajadores y proveedores
españoles que viven de esta enclave británico,
los gobiernos de las tres partes implicadas:
España, el Reino Unido y Gibraltar, impulsaron
el llamado “Acuerdo de Nochevieja”.
Un acuerdo político que, tal y como podréis
imaginar por su nombre, sucedió in extremis
un 31 de diciembre de 2020, y fijó un periodo
transitorio de cuatro años con medidas especiales
para Gibraltar.
(El Acuerdo de Nochevieja, cambiará por completo
la situación del Peñón con su entorno.
El acuerdo establece la libre circulación
de personas y mercancías, lo que supone incorporar
a Gibraltar por primera vez al espacio Schengen.
Esto conlleva la desaparición de la verja,
el paso aduanero y los controles que existían
en la frontera entre España y el territorio
birtánico. Lo que supone, por ejemplo, que
los británicos para entrar en Gibraltar tendrán
que pasar un control de pasaporte, cosa que
el resto de ciudadanos europeos no tendrán
que hacer. De hecho, el control migratorio
del puerto y el aeropuerto gibraltareños
estará bajo control de la Unión Europea,
concretamente del FRONTEX, la Agencia Europea
de la Guardía de Fronteras y Costas.
Y no solo eso, en principio en Gibraltar se
aplicará la política aduanera y de comercio
exterior de la Unión Europea, lo que también
afectará a los propios productos procedentes
del Reino Unido.
Asimismo las autoridades gibraltareñas tendrán
que poner en marcha cambios regulatorios para
equipararse a las normas comunitarias en materia
por ejemplo de IVA o Impuestos especiales.)
Es decir, que aunque siga estando bajo soberanía
británico, el Peñón quedará más unido
que nunca a la política comunitaria. Por
supuesto, las fricciones están garantizadas.
Sin ir más lejos, el 20 de julio de 2021
la Comisión Europea presentó el borrador
que sentará las bases de la negociación
de la relación futura entre ambas partes
una vez pasado el periodo transitorio de 4
años.
Entre otras cosas este borrador contempla
que el control de las fronteras dejará de
estar en manos del Frontex para quedar directamente
bajo control de las autoridades españolas
y sus cuerpos de seguridad. Lo que no tardó
en hacer estallar la furia:
(Reino Unido choca con la UE sobre el estatus
de Gibraltar post-Brexit - BBC
El secretario de exteriores ha acusado a la
UE de buscar “torpedear la soberanía británica
sobre Gibraltar”.)
Y ojo, porque en Gibraltar el debate está
servido. Mientras el gobierno defiende el
acuerdo con la Unión Europea, buena parte
de la oposición no lo tiene tan claro. Tienen
miedo de que las normas y exigencias comunitarias
puedan terminar erosionando la prosperidad
local.
En VisualPolitik estaremos ojo avizor. De
momento, turno para ti:
¿Qué te parece el caso de Gibraltar? ¿Logrará
convertirse este diminuto lugar en toda una
referencia mundial? De lo que has escuchado,
¿Qué te gusta y qué no te gusta?
Como siempre, déjanos tu respuesta por aquí
abajo en los comentarios. Y ya sabéis si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante no
olvides darle al botón de like.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.